bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
cette édition le festival solivert se
prépare à mort par un rendez-vous
musical important pour les groupes
amateurs locaux toutes les précisions
avec nos invités dans quelques instants
l'artiste Tristan Félix animé un
week-end d'écriture à la Maison de la
Poésie nous reviendrons sur l'atelier
découverte du monocondil vendredi 7
février le scarabée reçoit le groupe
nantais Elmer Food Beat de retour sur
scène avec un nouvel album Nicolas
Gervais Lisa pour rencontrer
grand rendez-vous musical à Maurepas le
festival show l'hiver reprend du service
pour cette 13e édition 7 groupes
répartie sur deux soirées donc ce sera
les 7 et 8 février un festival organisé
de concerts avec le café de la plage
d'une part et les studios de répétition
du cobalt à Maurepas bonsoir Lucile
Lambert bonsoir vous êtes donc chargé de
communication pour le café de la plage
et vous êtes venu accompagner de Yann
casuba bonsoir à vous vous êtes
régisseur et responsable des studios oui
c'est ça du cobalt donc à Maurepas Lucie
je commence avec vous première question
ce que pouvait nous rappeler un peu le
principe finalement de ce festival oui
alors le festival cholivet en fait c'est
le festival des studios de répétition du
cobalt et donc le cobalt si vous voulez
c'est une structure qui est quand même
très rapprochée du café de la plage
souvent on dit le café cobalt voilà donc
on s'est de structures qui sont quand
même
préparer physiquement donc voilà vous
êtes implantés dans de locaux de locaux
différents voilà et pour autant vous
menez un travail complémentaire
exactement on travaille vraiment sans
donc c'est la même équipe divisée en
deux mais voilà puisque chacun est dans
sa structure mais on travaille vraiment
ensemble voilà donc le but de ce
festival c'est de mettre en avant ces
groupes d'amateurs c'est ça exactement
c'est une sorte de vitrine pour eux
c'est vraiment le moment dans l'année où
on les met en valeur et on leur permet
de proposer leur travail en fait qui
réalise tout au long de l'année
ils travaillent avec beaucoup avec les
régisseurs donc c'est important aussi de
proposer quelque chose à ce niveau là
quoi de montrer ce qu'il fait dans les
studios en terme de scénographie de
travail sur le son voilà alors justement
Yann vous c'est groupe vous les
connaissez bien
oui voilà vous travaillez avec toute
l'année vous pouvez nous en dire
quelques mots alors il y a sept groupes
on va les citer et puis rapidement
donner un peu leur style oui donc il y a
7 groupes cette année qui sont qui sont
sélectionnés là pour le sol hiver donc
donc le festival se passe sur deux soirs
donc le vendredi on a Barrio libéré un
groupe de rock
chanté en espagnol en fait donc voilà
on a un groupe qui s'appelle divine qui
se définisse comme la Pink Punk en fait
c'est une sorte de rock pop un peu
électro en fait c'est assez pétillant on
va dire
et fesses d'hommes qui a un groupe de de
rock métal un peu plus un peu plus
énervé on va dire voilà et le samedi on
a quatre groupes cette fois c'était une
française qui fait du rock là pour le
coup
pardon il est accompagné
on a un groupe de de rockstoner donc
rock à guitare en fait qui s'appelle Aya
Monster qu'on connaîtrait très bien qui
a été accompagné aussi par la structure
et enfin
uku pop qui est un groupe de pop folk
ukulele avec c'est pas banal au café de
la plage
et on finit par par un groupe de reggae
qui lui a une bonne petite réputation
maintenant quand même dans les environs
qui s'appelle new reggae
je vous propose qu'on regarde une petite
compilation de quelques-uns des groupes
seulement parce que nous n'avons pas de
vidéo pour l'ensemble de ces groupes ils
sont ils restent amateurs donc on n'a
pas toujours de vidéos mais on va nous
on va regarder un certain nombre ça va
nous donner le temps de des deux soirées
tu ne peux rien faire du tout
trop
trop fou dans la
alors on se rend bien compte que il y a
différents genres musicaux comment vous
avez établi cette programmation cette
sélection qui passe dans quel ordre et
quel jour alors en fait de toute façon
on part sur sur un nombre de groupes qui
est plus ou moins préétabli plus ou
moins définis on n'a pas on est sur deux
soirées on peut pas faire passer
beaucoup beaucoup de groupes non plus
donc il y a déjà ce paramètre là qui
rentre en compte après après c'est une
optique c'est un choix c'est où on
décide de faire en fait des soirées
thématiques c'est-à-dire que là on cible
clairement un public c'était le cas l'an
dernier donc on cible clairement un
public pour pour un style musical ou en
tout cas un ensemble de styles musicaux
assez c'est bien défini ou alors on
ouvre l'idée là cette année c'était
plutôt ça c'était de mélanger un petit
peu les publics de mélanger les styles
et puis et puis voilà parce que chacun
aussi peut découvrir des choses
différentes que ce qu'il est que ce
qu'il écoute habituellement que les
copains qui viennent voir et voilà alors
comment vous les avez sélectionnés ces
roues puisque vous vous travaillez avec
beaucoup de toute l'année pourquoi la 7
et quels étaient les quelles étaient les
critères alors en fait on n'est pas là
non plus obligé le programmer un nombre
de groupes définis on va pas en gros on
va pas forcer non plus des groupes à
passer si ils se sentent pas prêts ou
sinon vous les trouve pas prêt parce que
l'idée c'est pas de se mettre en danger
non plus sur scène et puis d'en garder
un mauvais souvenirs
l'idée c'est plutôt même c'est plutôt le
contraire donc il y a ça et bon après je
libère c'est une belle vitrine pour les
pour les groupes du cobalt parce que
c'est pour eux une belle occasion de
passer au café de la plage c'est le café
c'est quand même une salle où il y a
aussi des pros qui passent etc donc
l'idée c'est d'avoir des groupes qui
sont un petit peu près qu'on a un
minimum de temps de jeu en fait donc ça
ça s'invente pas c'est pas des groupes
en général c'est des groupes qui ont un
petit peu de bouteilles du coup qu'on
peut présenter pour ce genre d'événement
ils ont une demi-heure trois quarts
d'heure de 7 des fois une heure donc
donc voilà en fait la sélection elle se
fait comme ça et en général quand on a
recette de cette acabula bah ça veut
dire qu'on a un petit peu pratiqué son
instrument et qu'on est un minimum à
l'aise sur scène du coup c'est des
groupes aussi qui ont un petit peu de
scène derrière eux en fait et alors
quand
il vient quel type de demande finalement
quel accompagnement
il y a du jaune groupe de petits lycéens
qui sait pas jouer qui vient monter son
groupe pour la première fois pour jouer
devant les copains ou pas d'ailleurs qui
découvre même des fois leur instrument
pendant les premières répètes etc au
groupe qui sont là qui sont je sais pas
40-45 ans qui sont là juste pour se
faire plaisir pour rejouer des des
standards qui connaissaient qui jouaient
avant etc et il y a des groupes qui sont
là eux pour essayer de se
semi-professionnalisé voir ce
professionnaliser qui veulent avancer
donc qui répètent eux la très
régulièrement parmi les groupes
la lessivales quels sont ceux qui
justement tentent vers la
professionnalisation par exemple
on en aurait deux qui sont vraiment
enfin qui apparaît très vraiment très
motivés très moteur qui suivent des
formations etc
faith down uko pop quand même qui sont
assez qui cherchent vraiment qu'ils ont
en démarche active pour faire vraiment
beaucoup de concerts et c'est promouvoir
un petit peu leur musique
après ça
dans le milieu on parle de semi-pro en
fait c'est un petit peu il y a quand
même pas mal d'étapes intermédiaires ou
voilà c'est ça se franchit pas comme ça
mais et d'autres groupes qui sont plus
en développement entre guillemets qui
sont en train de se faire un petit peu
leur identité leur sept et d'essayer de
se promouvoir aussi petit à petit mais
bon voilà ils ont pas tous des supports
de communication ils ont pas tous des
disques ils ont pas tous des clips ils
ont pas tous fait beaucoup de concerts
donc ils peuvent pas promouvoir ça
beaucoup par internet non plus donc faut
que tout ça ça se fasse un petit peu et
ça c'est ça se fait de manière
progressive en fait
et alors
professionnels et tout à fait adapté à
la pratique musicale donc là on est
vraiment dans une très belle salle donc
les groupes ils sont ravis quoi
c'est le 7 et le 8 que c'est en Entrée
Libre exactement quel est réservations
étaient préconisées mais il vous reste
enfin a priori on peut venir comme ça le
soir même ou est-ce qu'il faut vraiment
téléphoner pour réserver non alors voilà
on avait imposé la réservation
obligatoire pour ce cette petite
problématique justement de jauge on
avait peur d'avoir des foules de gens
devant la salle et bon là ça se fait
assez naturel mais finalement les gens
ils vont ils viennent ils vont ils
prennent leur place finalement ils
reprennent des habitudes comme ça donc
voilà je pense que ça va se passer cette
façon là les gens vont se présenter ils
vont récupérer leur place pour ceux qui
ne les ont pas pris avant les
coordonnées sont affichées pour vous
contacter si on souhaite s'assurer de sa
place et donc avoir une réservation
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu du casque alors nous on va partir
maintenant du côté de Guyancourt à la
Maison de la Poésie en fait où cette
tenue le week-end dernier un week-end
d'écriture mené par l'artiste Tristan
Félix dimanche les participants ont
découvert l'atelier du monocondie donc
c'est un style graphique byzantin datant
du 10e siècle un reportage avec Jonathan
Wilman
d'identité et une seule cette idée de
retrouver un fil qui parfois dans les
dans la vie de chacun était rompu et il
faut se comment dire s'amuser au musée à
retrouver ce fil là sans lâcher voilà et
occupé sur cet espace de la page qui est
un rectangle
occupé le plus grand espace possible en
poursuivant ce fil le plus loin possible
dans les recoins inexplorés parce que
dans la vie on est attelé comme je vous
le disais à des métiers à des fonctions
et on explore pas tous les recoins de ce
que l'on est à mon actif pas toutes les
personnes que l'on est la foule qui qui
s'ouvre en nous voilà et c'est
l'occasion comme ça de se dire
en s'inspirant d'un modèle ancien
un modèle ancestral qui ouvre une voie
un nouveau mode de développement
personnel toutes les stratégies
qui permettent d'ouvrir un espace et
d'ouvrir un champ sur ce que l'inattendu
justement et ouvrir toujours des portes
ce qui est intéressant pour développer
se développer au sens large la Maison de
la poésie à Guyancourt accueille pour
son prochain week-end d'écriture les 8
et 9 février la poète dramaturge Claude
Bert l'atelier sera dédié à l'univers
des héroïnes
retrouvons sans plus attendre Nicolas
Gervais pour sa chronique dans le casque
depuis 1992 il n'avait pas sorti d'album
vendredi 7 février au scarabée à La
Verrière se produira le groupe nantais
Elmer Food Beat grand retour sur scène
avec un nouvel album les rois du bord de
mer Nicolas Gervais a rencontré les
Elmer en écoute
Daniela
et oui après 20 ans ils reviennent avec
un nouvel album intitulé Les rois du
bord de mer et une nouvelle tournée qui
passera notamment le 7 février par le
scarabée à La Verrière voici Elmer Food
Beat dans le kiosque
fantastique le caoutchouc super doux
les filles j'en fais mon affaire
bonne manière dans les stations
balnéaires je suis le roi du bord de mer
20 ans parce qu'il est tellement bien
qu'il fallait bien 20 ans pour qu'il
mûrissent
voilà hein
pour s'échauffer on avait fait un quatre
titres avec les filles c'est fait pour
faire l'amour et tout ça des belles
chansons et là on a fait un vrai avec 12
chansons on a fait différentes choses
les uns les autres dans différents
groupes différents projets comme on dit
par chez par chez nous par chez vous
chez les gens intelligents on parle de
projet et puis bah on s'est retrouvé un
petit peu par hasard en 2002 on peut
dire que le Zénith de Nantes fin 2006 a
été un peu le déclencheur qui a dit hola
il se passe un truc quand même 5000
personnes quand au moment où on attaque
Daniela il se met à chanter Daniela tu
dis oh il s'est passé un truc quand même
sur scène on fait plein de vieux
morceaux et plein de on fait
pratiquement tout la nouvelle album plus
plein de jeux morceaux on mélange tout
non non on oublie rien au contraire on
mélange tout le 9 le vieux et c'est ça
qui est bien sur scène
sur la télécommande ça fera tout ce que
tu lui demandes happy partout tu
commences à comprendre
que le plastique c'est élastique
alors sur l'album en tant que album par
contre là ce sont pas de la scène on est
quand même sur une atmosphère vraiment
plus pop beaucoup plus pop même oh non
c'est la preuve que comme ça parce que
en fait le
premier à nous le dire mais nous le
refaire moi en tout cas je le ressens
pas du tout comme ça je trouve que même
le son est bien vachement plus rock que
les albums d'avant donc j'ai pas j'ai
pas du tout ce sentiment là mais ça
vient de la prod qui a été fait par
Mathieu ballet et voilà des arrangements
ça vient de là mais moi je suis pas trop
d'accord avec ça je trouve plus rock'n
roll que celui d'avant par exemple ou
que et surtout que le premier même c'est
la musique qu'on joue le rock pop c'est
ça a toujours été ça entre Marie et à la
mer le plastique on va dire entre les
house Martin et ACDC quoi
je suis l'homme à tout faire
on se voit charger pas et c'est parti je
ferai ce combat nous a construit car je
suis un robot le meilleur ami de la
ménagère
avec fonction sur ses panthère on a fait
plein de morceaux et puis après on a
demandé à Mathieu balai nous produire
c'est à dire qu'on a été il nous a
enregistré on a fait les bases batteries
dans un studio puis après on a été chez
lui dans sa maison au bord de la mer et
puis on a enregistré tout au fur et à
mesure chez lui que des nouvelles
chansons et puis c'était super qu'on
était au bord de l'eau il y a celui qui
a même l'idée ça peut être Lolo ça peut
être moins ça peut être que lui le
premier guitare c'est puis après on
répète tous ensemble au local et puis on
met ça
debout tous ensemble les paroles c'est
chacun ça peut être Lolo ça peut être
moi ça peut être que lui et puis voilà
c'est pas moi
c'est pas tantôt rigolo donc ils
écrivent pour tonton rigolo
et effectivement il y a forcément le
fait de savoir qui va interpréter la
chanson je pense que ça ça guide un peu
le
tu vois certaines paroles sont un peu
dirigées pour que m'en discute oui ça
machin n'est pas toujours d'accord bon
c'est toujours tout sauce qui a raison à
la fin donc de toute façon ça finit
comme lui dit même si kaloui ronchonne
dans son coin il voulait prendre
de marquer que certaines parties reste
dur comme du fer aux escalier j'aurais
tendre le linge plus de souci
icide il y a que pour plaire
aux satisfaire la finale c'est comme ça
qu'on est sur scène en fait à l'énergie
c'est puissant ça envoie du bois
j'ai d'excellents musiciens surtout qui
qui joue très très bien le rock n' roll
et puis moi je suis devant à faire
l'abruti et puis tout va très bien comme
ça je n'ai pas un
organe exceptionnel alors pour compenser
car j'ai horreur des chances des
chanteurs qui ont l'air de s'ennuyer sur
scène ça arrive à riches bien tout mais
il se passe rien et donc moi pour toi
faut que je compense et donc je bouge
je vais rentrer tout droit
et vise un peu la chance que tu as un
beau garçon comme moi un nouveau beau
qui vient d'arriver c'est notre limite
mais en beau qui vient d'arriver
ça fait 12 ans qui vient d'arriver
twistos là et ben il est hyper content
lui de reprendre la route moi je suis
content
peut-être que dans 10 ans on en aura on
arrêtera peut-être que dans 10 ans les
gens diront les pauvres gosses feraient
bien d'arrêter enfin bon on n'en sait
rien toujours est-il que tant qu'on sera
comme là
est un son ça continuera c'est sur je
suis
à quand tu me
prends pour rien
les filles c'est quand même un peu le
sujet principal de beaucoup beaucoup de
chanteurs faut bien avouer et mais sauf
que nous on sait écrire pour les filles
la différence on fait des vrais belles
chansons d'amour Merci à VOUS champion
du monde et donc à bientôt
merci Paris vous avez vu cette turbo
brosse et voici pour Elmer Food Beat et
maintenant on retrouve en plateau
Aurélia lalalalalala
chaque semaine donc dans la chronique
cinéphine nous vous proposons d'entendre
un professionnel du cinéma nous livrer
son coup de coeur aujourd'hui c'est au
tour de Cyril Haddad projectionniste au
cinéma l'espace Philippe Noiret des
Clayes-sous-Bois
le coup de cœur de l'espace Philippe
Moret cette semaine et le film tel père
tel fils film japonais en version
originale ce film raconte l'histoire
d'un architecte à vie de succès
professionnel il est marié et un enfant
de 6 ans sa vie va basculer le jour où
la maternité de l'hôpital va l'appeler
pour lui annoncer que de nourrissons ont
été échangés à la décence et son fils
biologique en fait vit dans un autre
milieu beaucoup plus modeste ce film
rappelle forcément le film d'Étienne
châties la ville est un long fleuve
tranquille traité sur le mode de la
comédie mais ce film là nous entraîne
plutôt sur le mode du mélodrame va faire
passer le spectateur du rire aux larmes
et va le bouleverser de d'un bout à
l'autre du film sans jamais sombrer dans
le pathos
ce film est à découvrir à l'espace
Philippe Noiret
retrouvez la semaine prochaine je vous
propose je vous propose pardon quelques
idées de sorties ces prochains jours
alors tout d'abord si vous souhaitez
assister à un concert inédit d'automat
le musicien est compositeur et fan de
son vrai nom François Morin qui est
aussi chef d'orchestre pas tout à fait
comme les autres mélange mélodie pop et
écriture classique c'est à découvrir
vendredi donc le 31 là à la batterie à
Guyancourt enfin les amateurs de BD
d’univers médiévaux et de preux
chevaliers pourront rencontrer Philippe
Lugi dessinateur de percevant c'est une
journée de dédicace qui est organisée à
la librairie lettre voisine avoisin et
c'est samedi enfin si vous avez envie de
passer une soirée rock rendez-vous
samedi à l'espace de Cauville à Voisins
toujours un concert de trois groupes
dans le cadre des samedis de la tour
organisés par l'association vessinoise
métassos voilà cette édition est à
présent terminée je vous retrouve donc
la semaine prochaine mercredi à 18h30
en direct d'ici là profitez de la
richesse de notre territoire de tous ces
lieux de culture à mercredi